well good morning everyone or okay it's
morning for me
afternoon for probably most everyone
else here
um i do wish i was in oslo actually uh
i'm in
uh i'm out of texas in the usa um and
it's very warm here
um and it's much nicer now as long i'm
sure i think yesterday here the high hit
something like 37c
so i would have much rather been and
also enjoying the beautiful weather
there
but uh we do the best we can with what
we have so um i hope everyone enjoys
this
uh so my name is jimmy bogard you can
find me on twitter at
jboguard and you can find this
presentation all the color behind it
on my github at github.com there's a
presentations repository there that
you'll find
has everything that you see here i blog
about this topic and a lot of others
on my blog at jimmybogar.com and i am an
independent consultant
i'm also a technical fellow at
headspring which is a software
consultancy out of austin texas
and uh let's see i've got an mvp award
um
i do a lot of open source stuff uh with
auto map or mediator
so um i've been doing domain durbin
design
in one form or the other since about
2003 or 2004
um and i've been over that time i found
myself
uh having different ways of applying
the different concepts inside of domain
different design initially when i got
started
uh with domain different design i
thought that everything that you needed
to do
was a lot of upfront design and once you
get the upfront design
and the whiteboarding and stuff then the
models just come out of that
so you have the conversations with the
business you talk it over your team
you build this nice lovely model and
then the code is supposed to be just
fantastic
but i often find is that that wasn't the
result i would see
is that even though my model looked
great the code still
didn't look that great so let's talk a
little bit about what
domain driven design is before we can
talk about how we refactor ourselves
into a good domain driven model so
domain german design in my words and by
the way
unfortunately the domain name design
book doesn't just like have a bolded
definition for what domain number design
is
for me i try to think of it as it's an
architectural design strategy
in which we selectively distill organize
and abstract
the body of knowledge from the real
world and users in the real world
to our software and so the goal of
domain driven design is not to represent
exactly the real world but to provide a
sort of
a distillation of the real world and to
software users can actually use
and i like to think of it very similar
to physics
where you have like very low level
quantum mechanic physics that
are really complicated math but as you
start to get higher up you have
simpler equations and simpler problems
they kind of encapsulate and abstract
the details away
if you get really small the really like
subatomic level then
those equations go out the door but as
we move up in
the size we can start to think of things
in a different abstraction layer
and domain-driven design is a lot like
that in which we're taking the real
world which is very messy
and kind of hard to deal with and saying
we need to distill that down to
something that users can actually use
we're not trying to represent
everything in the real world but a piece
of it a part of it
so that's uh we're not building software
that represents like everything that
could possibly happen in the world
so part of what you do with domain
driven design is you try to build a
model
that represents that design and this is
known
as a domain model and a domain model uh
actually predates the domain-driven
design book and uh
domain model i find the best definition
actually from a book myself there
the patterns of enterprise application
architecture and it defines a domain
model is
an object model of the domain that
incorporates both behavior
and data so we take that domain
domain knowledge we distill it into some
kind of
object model and we ensure that that
object model that we build
represents both the data and the
behavior of that domain
and that's the real key here that we
need to have both data
and behavior we don't just have data
because that would just be a database
and we don't have just behavior because
those will just be functions
it's the two together that really define
a
cohesive domain model
and these domain models move beyond just
kind of the nouns and verbs that we do
from
like kind of simplistic object modeling
we look at the relationships between the
things
we look at how that information changes
over time
and all those kind of uh considerations
pulled together
give us our domain model
so that's great we have this kind of
like ivory tower
you know perfect view of the world of
our domain model but we look at our code
after we do this domain modeling it
sucks like
the code is still really difficult to
read uh sure we have this this nice
object model represents our data but the
actual like the actual functionality of
our system
we find that that still doesn't look
great and so the the building blocks
of domain driven design don't really
solve this for you um it's not like we
could just take
all the different kinds of things in
domain modeling uh we have entities
aggregates services and that'll just
kind of magically produce
a well-defined cohesive domain model
so how do we get there and for this i
turn uh to a slightly older technique
of test urban design that tells us in
order to
build a well factored well
understandable system
we can follow these three basic steps we
write a failing test
we write a passing test and that last
critical step is to refactor
but most the system that i inherit most
of the
legacy systems or or systems that have a
well established body of functionality
don't necessarily have the first two
items they've kind of like well we've
got
some tests and some of the tests passed
but some of the tests fail but don't
worry we've commented those out so you
have to worry about those anymore
and so for these kinds of existing
systems we have a lot of existing
behavior
that we want to refactor into a well i
thought out well designed
domain model we have to get really good
at that third step
which is refactoring now luckily
we don't have to come up with all the
different refactoring techniques
on our own that these are
well-established names well-established
practices that we can leverage as part
of
our journey from taking a very
simplified view of the world into a very
rich
domain model so if we're looking at
what can we build on top of what
techniques can we choose from
there's three really great books that
define and describe different ways of
refactoring code into
cleaner code at the end my favorite
though is the working effectively with
legacy code book for michael feathers
it's a very long book that this
basically just how to add tests
to existing code and that's the that's
how you can work effectively with legacy
code
um and the other two great books that i
find are martin fallow's refactoring
book which has been updated to a second
edition
uh that describes uh techniques in the
small of how to refactor code
and then the techniques in the large are
they are described in the refactoring to
patterns book
and the refactoring uh the original
refactoring book was really about
looking at individual classes and
methods
and then refactoring to patterns is
trying to take that one step back and
say
we have all these design patterns and
they're not just a you know they're not
just a recipe or checklist we say oh
you've got all these different patterns
and our codes are most code must be
clean and good
instead it says let's look at code
smells exhibited
inside of our code base and use those
code smells to guide us toward
perhaps different patterns design
patterns that we can apply to help make
our code cleaner
so i want to look at an existing system
that exhibits all the right things in
terms of the names of things
so all the names of things look good
from the business perspective
but the behavior is hard to understand
and sort of lack in any kind of design
so the current state of this system is
uh this is a system for a
loyalty reward system so in these kinds
of loyalty reward systems
you have people that buy things from
stores and
if you want to get more value out of
your purchases
then you can join a rewards program and
those reward programs reward you for
loyalty for going to that store so the
idea is that the more you purchase from
that
uh from that store then you get points
or something
and then eventually you get uh you get
rewards for
um basically for guests for giving up
your personal information and purchase
history
you get the you get the rewards on the
other side so our domain model looks
like this
um i said three kinds of things we have
members we have rewards
uh our our business owner doesn't like
to call them rewards they call them
offers and then we have different types
of offers in our system we've got
um kind of some metadata around what
kind of offers we can give to our
different customers
and so in our domain model we represent
these
concepts as domain objects so we have
entities and aggregates
that represent these top-level concepts
of members of offers and
offer types we also represent the
relationships between those
as different navigational properties on
each of our domain objects
so in this picture for example i have a
member object
and a member has a set of assigned
offers and that's represented as a
collection property on that object
that i can go to a member object and i
can go look at then the list of their
assigned offers
we also have a reverse by looking at an
individual offer
then they can look to see who was the
member assigned to that one specific
offer
and finally offers are associated with
some kind of metadata information about
that offer
and that's that offer type uh class we
see at the bottom there
so every single offer has a type
associated to it and that
type helps describe the behavior of the
offer
as it's getting used throughout the
application
so i can take this picture and show it
to the business and there'd be nothing
here that they would disagree with
yes we have members and this is the
information about our members
oh yeah we have offers and this is the
information about offers and yes this is
they can even understand their
relationships just a member will have
many assigned offers uh an offer will
have a type associated with it
um maybe this is done in this kind of
diagram in a class diagram
uh sometimes i've seen it of course done
in kind of an innovative relationship
diagram or like a
class tables and a database but i should
be able to take the kind of
informational model
and share that with the customer in some
kind of abstract form and they should be
able to
understand what it means and also agree
with all the different names associated
with all the different
properties types and associations here
so i could show this to the business and
there would be nothing
they disagree with but you look at this
ask does this actually represent a
domain model
we go back to the definition the
definition of domain models that
incorporates both data
and behavior but looking at this model
where is the behavior well this domain
model doesn't live by itself
it's probably as part of some
application that's running or some
system
and so the behavior does exist somewhere
it's just not encapsulated
as part of the domain so if i want to
find out where
the behavior actually exists in the
system i look for those helper classes
and those have a lot of different names
um i've seen over the years
so uh the names of those classes
typically don't have anything that
describes the function that they
are so you have things like service
or handler or manager or controller
or page like all those things describe
kind of what it's doing but not
the behavior behind the scenes so that
that behavior does exist
somewhere in our application but it's
not encapsulated
inside a domain model so what i want to
do from here
is take an example of one of these
services
and refactor its code until it's
encapsulated inside the domain model
the reason why i want to approach it
this direction because
this picture is super easy to do
with a business i'd say super easy it's
relatively easy to do with the business
we can whiteboard this we can we can
erase things and move things around and
come to a pretty good understanding of
what the domain model's information
shape
needs to look like the behavioral shape
though is much harder
to whiteboard the behavioral shape you
almost have to start with code
and refactor into the shape it needs to
be we can make educated guesses
sometimes
about where the behavior needs to be but
those are just guesses
in terms of where the behavior needs to
go and what it needs to look like
i want the code to tell me where it
needs to go
and the way it's going to tell me where
it needs to go is through the code
smells it exhibits
and the way i know where it's uh where
where it ends up
that that's the right place is that
after refactoring
the design is cleaner and more
understandable so
i want to take something that is inside
of that services folder
and i want to refactor it towards my
domain model
so instead of just refactoring kind of
in a bubble
for me the behavioral domain model uh is
really
formed by refactoring the behavior
towards
the domain model so that the domain
model truly becomes a rich behavioral
and
data structure so i'm going to switch
over now
to visual studio
okay so i have here uh
in this case i'm actually using a
library that i wrote uh called mediator
and meteor is basically uh just a
library to help encapsulate requests and
responses in the system
and i kind of think that this is like
many domain services from the main
driven design book
um and that they represent exactly one
function or one operation that you
perform
so i'm really big on vertical slice
architecture
the idea that i put everything related
to a feature next to each other
and so this represents all the
functionality and behavior
required to assign an offer to a member
now this class by itself um this is my
first
go-around at tritonis and when i first
write any of these kind of handlers or
services
i want to make it as dumb and procedural
as possible
and the final step in that red green
refactor step
um you don't have tests then i guess
it's just a factor
it's a final step to be able to say now
we need to refactor it now that's the
part i usually leave out in my
in my talks about vertical slice
architecture i just say just make it as
dumb as procedural as possible and then
just refactor at the end and
everything's great um
but not many people know how that looks
like or what what it means to actually
refactor something
so that's why i want to walk through
here so this class completely
encapsulates the work to assign an offer
to a member
i have one single input which is this
offer request object
and that carries the two pieces of data
required to perform that operation
i need to know the the id of the member
that you want to assign to
and i need to know what kind of opera
what type of offer
i want to assign to that member so those
these three pieces of information
the data the member id the offer type id
and the operation you want to perform
assigning an offer those three pieces
together are able to encapsulate the
work
necessary to assign an offer to a member
so let's look at this fun class
um and it's not short it's
kind of long not terribly slightly long
because i don't have hours to refactor
this we only have about 45 minutes
uh but i wanted to represent the kinds
of different things i typically see
happening
in a given handler for one of the kind
of normal projects that i work on
so let's walk through these individual
steps one by one
well the first step we have to do in
this class is
well we have to load some information so
in this case i'm just using
entity framework so this is just a db
context uh and that dbcontext we're
going to find
the member by id we're going to find the
offer type
id now the work required to assign an
offer to a member
is not as simple as just inserting a row
into a database so i'm doing some more
complex logic behind the scenes so
that's why i'm actually pulling back
these objects as opposed to just like
an insert statement in the database so
it's more complicated than just sql can
handle so that's we have it in c sharp
okay got the member got the offer um the
first thing we need to do is understand
what is the value of the offer that we
want to give to the client
well for this the client decided that uh
code wasn't good enough
so we wanted to have a rules engine to
be able to do this work and this rules
engine is behind an api
and so this first set of calls here
is about calling some api be able to
calculate the offer
for a given member based on the their
email address and the offer type
so all the work behind the scenes
they're like oh this this member is like
a
super duper member that has a lot of
history so we're going to give him a
good offer
where this other member is maybe not so
not such a frequent shopper so we're
going to give him a lower value
uh lower value offer so the
the logic to figure out what we should
offer that uh
what what the offer value should be is
in behind this api call
so that's step one step two we need to
calculate the expiration date
now for this system we have two kinds of
uh expiration types based on my uh based
on my offer type
so if i go to my offer type object we've
got the name
the number of days that could be valid
we have expiration type an expiration
type represents
two ways of doing expirations one is an
assignment based expiration saying that
this offer is valid until the specific
uh
date when that offer is assigned
or it's on a fixed date so you could say
like we have a
a new year's uh new year's day offer and
that offer is good for the next week
and so that offer is good from january
1st to january 7th
sometimes we have a offers based on when
they are signed and so that's the first
one there
so whenever i sign the offer it's good
for the next seven days the next 14 days
the next 30 days whatever that is
but it's more of a sliding expiration so
whenever i sign the offer
that's when that offer uh is expiring
so that's what this switched switch name
it is
it is calculating the logic for uh when
that offer should expire
with the switch statement so now that i
have the value of the offer
and i've got when it expires now i can
do the final piece of work of assigning
the offer to the member
so down here we are going to instantiate
a new offer
passing it all the properties that it
needs we're going to
add that offer to the assigned offers
collection on the member object
and the next thing i do is going to
increment the number of active offers
for that user
so this is something that's a calculated
property on this object that i need to
keep track of to understand
like when the user logs into the to the
system they just see a big
you know a big number at the top that
says here's the number of offers you
have
so instead of me having to make all
those calculations behind the scenes
having to fetch additional data i'm just
going to pre-calculate that information
and store it on the member object
themselves
and the final piece i need to do is to
save
those objects so i'm going to add the
offer to the offers dbset
and entity framework and then finally
save it
so i load the objects perform some
calculations
make the appropriate associations and
then finally save the objects
if i look at most of the work in my
system it's basically this
i load some data i do a bunch of work
and then i save the data and so the the
loading and the saving part
is the most boring aspect of the system
the interesting part is the stuff in the
middle you can actually tell here
because
it got so complicated that we actually
started to
comment our code about what this logic
was doing so we can separate out
logically like this is the part where
we're calculating now for the value
this is the part where we're calculating
the expiration date and this is why
we're actually assigning the offer to
that member
so i've been looking at this code and
this
obviously is complex enough that we're
adding code comments
then the very next thing i'm going to do
is say how can we
how can we makes this code cleaner so
the first step that i would look at
for this kind of code is applying a
refactoring
and the first free factor i look at
applying for something like this
describe a long method
that is a refractory node is compose
method and components compose method for
factoring involves
uh taking every single block of
logically defined set of operations
and extracting individual methods for
each of those sets of operations
at the same conceptual level so i can
i can determine what those conceptual
operations are by the code comments
if i have code comments that separates
out these individual steps
instead of me having comments describing
the code although we have
self-describing code
and then i will extract methods for each
of these operations
so i'm going to first extract a method
here now i'm using
resharper and i'll show you why in a
second why i want to do that
so i'm going to say extract a method for
this block of code
and the name of the method i'm just
going to make
calculate offer value
the same text to the comment like if
it's important enough to have the
comment called that then let's call the
method the exact same thing
so all right so that block of code was
extracted out i can go down and look at
it see if everything looks okay
yeah everything looks okay uh this
doesn't look right i don't know why i
have a temporary variable here so i can
go ahead and
inline that because i don't need that
additional variable
and everything looks okay here okay
now um what if i don't like this like uh
i didn't look like my code doesn't look
better um
every refactoring that i have should
have an equal and opposite
refactoring to reverse back the
operations i just performed
so that is available to me in resharper
i can say inline method
which is the reverse of extract method
when an inline method
it should go back to where it was before
everything's back exactly where it was
huzzah
i like where it was before the reason
why i want to show that is uh it's very
important for me that
for me to to have confidence and have
safety
associated with these refactorings it's
not enough that i just have
a one-way refactoring i really need to
have the reverse as well
so if i make a change to my code and i
don't like what i see
i can reverse that change as well
through an opposite refactoring
and i won't always have the undo uh
button available to me or the undo
undo operation i may have to have that
logical undo in this case which is
inline that method so let's go back i
liked what it was before
value equals the weight calculate offer
okay so the next place we have is
calculating the expiration date let's do
the exact same thing we have there
so highlight the the code we want to
extract a method for
extract a method in this case we're
going to call it calculate
expiration date
and the final one is assigning the offer
so extracting this
set of code by itself
assign offer
and then the final piece is there's a
these two things kind of go together of
saving
saving the thing so let's extract a
method for that as well
save offer
okay so
this may be where i stop on a lot of
work factoring as i do
that says okay you know we uh
we had a long method it was too long we
didn't extract just one method what we
want to do is extract individual methods
for each set of
operations that we have so the next
developer coming and looking at this
oh let's just get rid of these comments
we don't need this do we yep yep
instead of having comments describe
these sets of operations we have methods
to describe the operations
when i have those methods it's very easy
for me to tell exactly the information
required to be able to perform those
operations so i can see
calculated for value requires the member
and the offer type
calculated expiration tape just requires
the offer type and assigning the offer
requires the member the offer type
the value and the expiration date as
well
so it's very for easy for me to see for
each individual operation
exactly the information necessary to
perform those operations
okay but that's not that's not quite
good enough because
we're doing domain-driven design and i
want to refactor this code towards the
domain model
and right now this this code and logic
is still just inside the single
service handler class so let's look at
each of these methods one by one
and figure out how we can refactor that
code towards
a domain model and let's start at the
top
i've got this method here called
calculate
offer value and this calculate offer
value
actually let's change the order of the
parameters real quick i want the
cancellation token
so i just got rid of that thing but i
guess you're supposed to use it all the
time
uh let's move cancellation so you can
laugh so it doesn't confuse me and so we
have the the member
and the offer type and if i look at this
code
it's not like it's dealing with any one
of these objects by itself so it's
dealing with both member information
and offer type information so i don't
think i can move that logic just to one
of those objects
but if i wanted to do any other kind of
testing
for this individual handler be a bit
difficult because i have this dependency
on an http client
so what we can do is
move this method out somewhere else into
a separate service
so that that service is then
encapsulated for
or encapsulates all the logic needed to
calculate the offer value for a member
and a given
uh offer type
okay so the first thing we're going to
do is extract a class
so i've got my my little carrot on this
one method i'm going to say refactor
and extract a class and this will tell
me
ask me first what's the name of the
class we're going to call it so let's
call it offer
value calculator and only things we're
trying to do here
is name it based on the the uh the
responsibility and the role of this
object
so things that don't really describe the
role like like service
manager helper those don't really
describe the behavior associated with it
so i try to make
the last part like the the name of this
thing
represent the verb that it's trying to
perform so it's a calculator it
calculates an object
um it needs to use some objects to do
its work so i'm going to say yep you
need to pull that thing over
and that's now going to be a a member on
that target object
and this method is private so we need to
go ahead and make that public
and click next and
now we have oh here we go uh offer value
calculator
that accepts an hp client and now it has
this public method
for calculate offer value and then down
here below
we've got the offer value calculator um
but now it's getting instantiated
uh directly inside of here so i'm going
to change that a little bit
i'm going to uh actually let's do this
first let's
extract an interface here because the
overall goal here is to have
my service class not depend on a a
concretion here
especially when dealing with external
dependencies of an hp client so i'm
going to
extract an interface for
this class called i
offer value calculator okay so this
interface now represents
uh the operation to calculate an offer i
don't like that name
it's redundant i have i offer value
calculator with method called
calculate offer value that seems
redundant so let's rename that to
calculate
okay so now my usage instead of
calling out to a private method i've
extracted that method
extracted the class from that method and
now i have an interface that represents
that method as well
now my class though isn't using the
interface so i'm going to refactor this
to say
use base type where possible so instead
of me using the concrete type
use the interface type
and now the class uses the i
offer value calculator instead of the
offer value calculator
and the final piece is to i don't want
to pass in an http client
to this class i really just want to pass
in the interface to the offer value
calculator
so i can refactor this and say introduce
a parameter
for the offer value calculator it's
going to be a type i offer value
calculator and the thing that can be
removed now
is the http client click next
there are new uses the constructor
because everything's dependence
injection huzzah
the value the new parameter we lost next
and
it didn't quite sign it
there we go so uh we now
get a this uh service interface in for
the offer value calculator
and then now the work to calculate the
offer
based on the member offer type is
encapsulated from this handler class
i don't care how or why that offer gets
calculated but the work done
necessary to do that stuff is now in a
separate class that performs at work
so let's move these classes to separate
files
because it's getting annoying for me to
look at that stuff
okay
now if i look at this offer value
calculator there's not really anything
else
i would expect to pull out of this like
it's now it's
code just dealing with calculating that
that member based on offer type
and in fact i may even do things like
well do i need the whole member object
and just pass in the email
and the name of the offer type we'll
leave that for a future refactoring
i do need to make sure though now that
i've introduced this interface
i should go to my di configuration and
ensure that
at transients i
offer value calculator
so a little bit of wiring to get the
dependency injection stuff up and going
assuming i have that in my application
but this ensures that my handler now no
longer depends directly on this like
external web service thing
and it says have that external web
service thing encapsulated behind
a service and that service has this
interface behind it
so my handler now doesn't have to worry
about like the
the direct logic of calling this
external web service anymore that's not
that's now encapsulated
so i think we're done with that first
method the first method is moved out
into its own individual service
uh at this point i'd run on my unit
tests uh wait i don't have any so i
guess everything is green
and let's move on the next one okay so
the next method we have in our list is
calculating the expiration date
okay so we'll look at this a few things
i noticed first
there's no async no wait so it's not
calling off into any kind of external
things to do its work
and the object being passed in is just
the offer type so if i go to this
i receive an offer type and return a
daytime
and it's static so that tells me that it
doesn't use any state
for this object and the only information
it uses is the information
on this offer type object passed in
so what that tells me is that this
method
is very much concerned with some other
method
of with some other object and that code
smell
a few names for this um is known as
inappropriate intimacy so i have code
somewhere else very uh that is concerned
very much about someone
another object over here and so um
i should be able to look at this and say
this this logic is 100 dealing with this
other object
how about i move this logic to that
other object
and so we can do that so um
there's a there's a there's a slow and
fast way to do this i'll do it the slow
way first
uh the first thing i would do is i can
move this so i can say
move to another type i'm going to move
to
model dot offer type
okay click next it's going to tell me
well it was private before
so we're going to need to make it public
now click next
okay and now that method is gone here
now it's moved
over to my offer type class this isn't
exactly what i wanted though because
it's a static method dealing with
this object uh i'd really just want to
have that method be an instance method
so there's another refactoring for that
say
make method non-stack what resharper's
going to do is look at the parameters
and say okay instead of you passing in
the object if you want to make it an
instance method i will need to use the
instance
fields or properties on that parameter
so it's going to convert
all of these parameter usages
offertype.blah
into instance properties or instance
usages click next
huzzah now it's an instance method i
don't pass in the offer type anymore i
just use the offer type
object itself and now over my handler
up here i say offer type that calculate
expiration date
as opposed to calculate expiration date
passing in the offer type
i'm gonna undo this because there's
actually a quicker way
undo undo now my method is
back on my handle object
let's perform this refactoring again
except this time
i'm going to go straight to make method
non-static
and this will move it directly from this
object to the other one
make it public make it non-static use
all the instance properties all in
welfare one fell swoop
down from here go from my offer type
here's my offer type now with the
correct calculated expiration dates
and now the method has been moved
successfully from this object
which is just a dumb service object over
to the actual domain object
that represents that behavior
okay now let's look inside that object
now that the behavior has been moved
with our place and look at the contents
of it to see if there's anything we want
to refactor here
well it's really just a switch statement
um which isn't
terrible by itself but a lot of the
times
in the systems that i use that have an
enumeration
we find switch statements littered
across our application
dealing with the different values and
those enumerations
so there's not one spot i could put that
logic so right here
this is this is logic very specifically
to assignments
of kinds of expiration types this is
logic very specific to
fixed type of expiration types wouldn't
be nice if i could move
that behavior over to the enum so that
the behavior around different kinds of
expirations
was encapsulated in one location however
we can't do that because enums are just
like fancy numbers
fancy name numbers um they don't really
allow us to have any kind of behavior
associated with them
we can put metadata on top of them so i
can decorate these different
values with attributes so like
kind of display information or things
like that but that's just additional
data and metadata it's not additional
behavior
so if i have the case where i have a
switch statement about
an email that i see a lot of different
places all these different switch
statements
what i would like to do is to move all
those different logic for all those
different cases
into one individual spot so that i can
see all the behavior related to
assignment type expirations in one spot
and all the behavior related to
expiration type x a fixed type
expirations in one spot as well
so we have a problem here though uh c
sharp today does not have any kind of
fancy enumeration types there are
proposals in c sharp 10 to have fancier
enumeration types and uh if i was brave
i would have installed the visual studio
preview but i'm not quite that brave yet
so instead we can leverage some open
source private projects
to provide additional behavior around
e-num kind of types
and so i've already actually pulled this
one in um this package
is from steve smith and it's known as
smart enum and smartdom is basically
a hybrid between classes and
enumerations
so what would that look like
so over my expiration type this is just
a
enum okay i'm going to change this to be
a class
so it's class expiration type it's going
to inherit from
smart smart enum
and because of funny generics business i
have to say it's a smart enum of itself
which is weird looking but whatever
okay and it needs a constructor and the
constructor
uh takes two things the name just what
you see
and the value which is how it's going to
be persisted or stored behind the scenes
my application shouldn't really care
about the number but the database
probably does
and the final thing to do is convert
these two public enum types
to public uh public properties
or public fields on this type to
represent those two fixed values
i could say instead of assignment being
1 i'll say
public static read-only expiration
type assignment equals
new expiration type
and the name is name of
assignment and the value is one
okay do the same thing for fixed we have
a fixed type
name fixed and the value is two
okay um the last oops too far
the last thing is i don't want anyone to
create these sort of things so let's
make this constructor
private sure and we have a private
constructor
um so i can only have these two specific
kinds of things but now i have a class
instead of a method so i have a place to
put this information
so go back over here okay
we have this calculate expiration date
right and it's dealing with this
expiration type
um but what i can do
is extract a method for this part that's
dealing with expiration type
extract method and
[Music]
calculate
expiration date
and it'll probably give me
yeah those two names are the same um so
what i want to do is move
this method over to expiration type
okay now this is going to be expiration
type
dot calculate expiration date and over
my expiration type
i've got a public method
and i pass in the offer type and i get
the information
out of there so
pass in this and
instead of having all this temporary
variable nonsense
let's just return
so you notice that this is not quite as
clean
with uh keyboard shortcuts as some of
the other ones or the the tooling
that's okay sometimes these these dragon
takes
multiple steps multiple jumps so i try
to be very careful about those
and once i complete them go ahead and go
and run all the tests commit to ensure
everything got moved over correctly
so the calling code doesn't care about
this though it just knows to call the
expiration dates over my handler
but what i've done is moved all the
logic for the different expiration type
calculations over here it doesn't work
though right because we have a switch
around the expiration type and so this
is incorrect what we really want
is uh assignment kinds to have this
and fixed kinds that have that
so there's a there's a few ways we can
do this the first thing um
we could do is just say uh switch
expiration type
uh dot value
and this value is going to be one
and two just temporary we'll fix this in
a second
um and this so this the next thing i
want to do is have um
let's figure out what to do with the
switch statement so the switch statement
um is complex conditional logic and so
one of the ways i can
fix a code smell of complex conditionals
is replacing
this is from the refactoring to patterns
book replacing a conditional
expression with a strategy pattern
and so now that i have a class that
represents
this individual set of behaviors and i
also have
individual properties or fields
representing the two kinds of expiration
types i now have a hook
to be able to provide a strategy for
each kind
of expiration type of my system so what
i'd like to do is
move this logic of calculating the
expiration date
to an assignment expiration and
the other kind of expiration where i'm
uh going based off of
the begin date over to the fixed
expiration type
so let's do that the first thing i want
to do is
i'm going to make this method virtual
so that it can be overridden in drive
classes the next thing i'm going to do
is
create different derived classes for
each of these expiration types so i'll
have a private class
assignment type
and that's going to inherit from the
expiration type
class it needs a constructor but the
constructor now i don't need to pass it
a name and a value
actually i'll just take what we had
before
and say that is the values you're going
to pass in and you don't actually need a
constructor because
i know for assignment types these are
the values you should use
okay so do the same thing for fixed
fixed type will have its own expiration
type
as well fix type
x type fixed
and value of two
okay so i've got assignment type assign
type thank you spell check
and fix type those don't do anything yet
other than encapsulate the name
and the value so over here instead of me
using the
uh the base types of these i'll just say
new
type and this is
new fix type
[Music]
okay so uh the behavior is exactly the
same though
so uh i have drive types over here but
the virtual method is still executed
every single time
so what i want to do the last little
piece is move the actual behavior for
calculating expiration date
over to as an overridden member to each
of these different assignment types
so over here i can say override
calculate expiration date
and its behavior is going to be
this the body of that
switch statement so it says daytime.days
and we'll do the same thing
with the other one now this one's a
little bit more complicated
it's got like if else throw
junk so let's put that in there
um and so let's say return that based on
the offer type
uh this looks like it can be simplified
there's some grayed out move or done it
else
uh convert to conditional operator uh
this says i can use the null coalescing
expression
and let's use an expression body number
so that all gets distilled down to um
use the begin date add days offer valid
if this expression returns null
then throw an exception because you need
a begin date for that piece
so this point um it's overridden so each
possible value of expiration types has
overridden its specific strategy
for how to calculate expression date
this point i would run my tests
that existed and verified that all tests
passed
and then finally that i know that that
those different strategies
are in place for everything this point
this method is no longer used
so i can actually convert this class to
an abstract
class and change
this method from a virtual method that
that has a
default behavior now it's going to be an
abstract method with no behavior that
has to be filled in
by each individual attempted individual
strategy
so what i've done here is i've converted
an enum that had only data and no
behavior
to an enum class that includes both data
and behavior
because enums have fixed values and
effectively those fixed values become
strategy implementations for the
behavior in my system
so as i encounter new new fun and
exciting switch statements
my system what i'll do is i'll convert
those to abstract methods
on this class and the implementations
will be the implementations of each
strategy
so instead of trying to be instead of me
trying to make the switch statement
better
i just got rid of it and replaced it
with a strategy pattern
okay now i i still have to make sure
that this actually works
with the rest of my system and the
typical hang up with this kind of
approach
is well i have a database i need to make
sure that this thing
can actually be saved to the database
because i can't i can't just pretend
like the database doesn't exist
i need to know how to convert this
information into like save statements to
the database or update statements or
inserts
and so what you can do here is really
going to depend on
how your domain model gets saved so some
folks
um they make their domain models
separate from the persistence models and
so this persistence model of entity
framework or [ __ ] or whatever it might
be
it's loaded into your domain model where
the behavior is that we kind of
completely separate those two things
i find that entity framework and most
orms are good enough
that i don't have to separate these two
things because that's a bit of work
and so i just combine the two together
into a single model that represents both
data and behavior
so i just need to make sure that my orm
can handle how to save this thing
so how can i handle that well
it turns out it can and the way i do
that
is to configure on model
creating model builder
dot entity
of offer type
property of
expiration type and then i'm going to
give it a conversion
and say that the conversion i need to
know how to save it and how to load it
let's say the way that you save the
thing
is going to be
that value okay so that's how we save
the object into the database
that even though it says object in
memory when i go to save it it's just
going to be the numerical value
i could choose anything from there i
could have chosen the name as opposed to
the value but we're going to make things
simple and make things a value and the
next piece is okay now that i have the
value
how do i how do i convert that to the
object model that you have
and so for that that's where that smart
enum package helps me out it's actually
got a bunch of helper methods to be able
to
load the right object based on its
individual value so i can go to
expiration to type
value goes to expiration type
dot from value the value from the
database
okay that was pretty easy i save it as
an integer and when i load the integer
back i just use this enumeration class
helpers method
to find the correct property or field or
instance
and use that uh use that instance so
behind the scenes
um this will look at the different
public static read-only fields and find
the right one in case it's assignment
and load that as the correct instance so
i'll go to
in my object model actually use that
assignment type in my object model
so going back to my handler
i've now encapsulated the expiration
dates
logic all the way down to the actual
enumeration class and use a strategy
pattern
to be able to pick the right strategy
for calculating calculating the
expiration date
based on the expiration type that it is
okay so i've got the expiration type got
the
the offer value the last little piece is
this assign offer method
so this is sign offer method uh
there's a lot of stuff it's going to
create an offer object and then the next
piece is going to
assign that offer to the user now this
is the this is the first kind of smell
i see is that um this
property number of active offers needs
to be
consistent with this property over here
unfortunately there's no connection
between those two things
i can do uh you know remember do i sign
off first that
add range had a whole bunch of them that
delete or move
remove all remove range truncate ken cat
like all sorts of things
because that's value that property on
that field
is just a list
and lists have a lot of methods that are
probably not supported by the business
so the first way to do is to make sure
that those two things really get changed
together
is to fix this this issue of i can do
anything
with this list of assigned offers so
let's encapsulate these two things first
so
i want these two things to happen
together so the first thing i'm going to
do
is extract a method
it's called assign offer
this time the assign offer method takes
a member and offer
the offer has already been created over
here i'm going to move that method
by saying make method non-static it'll
ask me where i want to move it to i want
to move it to the member
object so that's member.assignoffer
passing in that offer object
now a site offer has the encapsulation
of
adding the offer to the assign offers
list and bumping up the number of active
offers but i still haven't fixed
this problem which is that public list
of t doing all this sort of junk so this
point i'd look at what does the orm
supports to be able to encapsulate
this collection access and it turns out
af core
offers a lot so what ef core can allow
me to do is to
use a backing field for this actual
collection and only expose
what is necessary to expose let me do a
couple things first i'm going to do is
i'm going to
two property there it is two properties
backing field okay
so i've now got a private list of
assigned offers
and i don't actually ever want to have
the setter so i'm going to remove that
setter
because
in any framework my orm knows when it
sees a property like this that has elena
getter
it will look for a field that has
camelcase with an underscore
a bunch of other naming conventions i
can even give it a name if i want to as
the thing it's actually going to add
those items to
so make that read-only and
the final piece is i no longer want to
use an enum or list of this i don't want
to expose your list directly and
sometimes you say
this one needs to be an i innumerable
of offer and now down here instead of me
uh manipulating the list through the
property i'm manipulating through
this uh this field this backing field
let's uh also make this
setter private so we don't allow anyone
else to set this property
except for our own individual object so
now with this in place um i don't let
anyone do anything
with my uh offers instead
i only allow them to go through kind of
the front door and say i you can look at
the
the the list of offers the collection of
offers that's a read-only enumerable
um list if you want to do some operation
you have a method on my object to be
able to perform that so now this
collection is encapsulated the usage is
encapsulated from the calling classes
over here looks exactly the same i go
assign offer blah blah blah blah
and away we go
now the last piece i want to do is um
i've got the logic separated
for assigning offers separate from the
actual domain object itself
so i've got like the the offer value
calculated over here
and i've got the offer assigned over
here um what i really like to do is have
the member itself really fully
encapsulate all the work necessary
to be able to assign an offer to a
person but everything's kind of
separated out so let me first inline
this method
and
offer offer and
i'm going to now extract an entire
method
for all the operations related to
assigning that
that offer so i'm going to extract a
method
for kind of all the business logic
sign offer and let's move our
fund cancellation token all the way to
the end
okay so i say a sign offer
this does all the work to assign the
offer and then finally
uh returns that value back out if i look
at this method
and again it's dealing mainly with the
member object
so it's got like it's some offer
creation stuff but it's calculating
based on the member
um it's doing some stuff for overtime
but if i look at the logic it's it's
it's mainly a member let's see remember
let's see one two three places offer
type
uh three places as well um but it's it's
it's an operation i'm doing on the
member
so what i'd like to do is take this
logic
uh assigning an offer and move that
logic to the domain object itself
so let's try to do that and just see
what happens so
i'm going to move this method
it's going to ask me where do you want
to move this to i want to move it to the
member object
it will be encapsulated access rights
will be extended so
uh it's going to try to deal with this
sign off there we go the handler object
um i don't want to pass on the handler
object i don't want to pass in the value
the field a property to that um really
what i'll do is is take
those things and make that a parameter
so i can highlight the value that i see
there and say
extract parameter and safely remove the
handler i don't want to pass in the
entire handler
just give me the offer value
and finally let's move these
around so i passed the offer type then
one to assign the calculator
the cancellation token and i'm good to
go unless do i really need this assign
offer method over here
probably not so let's inline that
okay so with this in place i've got
um a completely encapsulated method for
assigning an offer
it does take a dependency through the
method argument
and then it uses that dependence to call
back out to the calculator saying
i need you to calculate your stuff based
on me and the offer type being passed in
this pattern is known in the c-sharp
world as double dispatch
where i'm passing in a service and then
i call that service for the right
parameters for it to do its work
so back in my handler
i don't actually need this anymore
uh let's just remove that all together
and now
this takes the cancellation token okay
so uh now looking at this picture
i've got my save logic my students
my load logic in one place in my handler
or this domain service the next thing it
does is delegate 100
off to the domain model to do the actual
behavioral work
once i get that object created in the
business logic completed
i now call the save method so it's load
do work save and the actual do work is
now 100 encapsulated inside my domain
model
everything necessary to actually perform
the business logic of assigning the
offer to the user is now
as part of this individual method
the nice thing about this is you can
look at this domain model and now this
domain model is actually
unit testable because this domain model
is 100 encapsulated it's not calling out
to other services
any dependencies it has are passed in
through these uh
abstractions so in this case the
abstraction is this api
service for for calculating an offer
that's now just passed in as a
as a parameter to an individual method
for that one individual
operation and in a unit test i can then
stub that out fake it out provide a
different you know a different value
based on different inputs and now this
this domain model is now 100
unit testable over my domain service
class which is what this is this handler
at this point i'm done i would almost
certainly integration test this
with an actual database but i'm not
trying to test all the logic behind the
behavior
i really just wanted to make sure that
kind of happy path testing
i can load the objects i can perform the
business logic and save them
otherwise um this code is as good as it
needs to be i don't need to do anything
else here
so what do we see here we saw
a lot of refactoring i was using a lot
of the tool set to be able to do so
i was working in very small incremental
steps but one of the things i was doing
was
refactoring with a purpose and that
purpose is looking at
the design smells associated with my
usage of these different objects
and aligning my refactoring
towards the domain model so instead of
pushing out into stateless functions or
other stateless classes
i was moving that behavior towards the
domain model
as was necessary so that my domain model
is now
a rich behavioral entity with
all the operations available to it on
that entity and it's
100 encapsulated so for future things i
could do here
um you see there's a lot of public
getters and setters i could probably fix
that
uh things like um there's no
constructors associated to ensure that
these objects are set up correctly
i would still likely go through and add
those kinds of things but for
refactoring this one individual method
i think it's good enough so
that was domain driven refactoring where
i am using domain german design to build
that domain model
and i'm using refactoring techniques to
build out that behavioral model that
domain driven design says we need
by using refactoring techniques and code
smells it ensures that the behavioral
model that i create
is based on the true behavior in the
system and not something
whiteboarded or just in our imagination
it's based on the actual code and the
actual code
cells we see in the application so by
using refactoring techniques and code
smells it ensures that our domain model
is as cohesive
and self-contained as it can be because
we're using the real actual behavior of
the system to do so
so thank you very much if you have any
questions i'll be on ye old slack
um afterwards otherwise if you want to
see more information about this you can
go to my github.com presentations this
entire example will be up there
a before and aft review you can also
read more
on the books i showed earlier the
refactoring book
and their factoring to patterns book i
hope you enjoyed it and i hope you have
a great
rest of the conference thank you